Hi, my name is Daniel Pham,
and welcome to "This Week In
Android Development,"
Monday, December 9, 2013.
Last week my ethnic doppelganger
made his debut on camera
to provide you with
the week's updates.
Our first episode of
"UXD" aired starring
Nazmul and his guest of
the week, Izabel Idris.
They introduced you all to UX.
Stay tuned for more episodes
in this series in the coming
weeks.
Lastly, Neto gave us
a translated edition
of app indexing in Portuguese.
This week, Todd and Wolff
will host an episode
of "Game On" where they'll talk
about stuff that I can't really
talk to you about yet.
Look for this episode
to air tomorrow.
That's it for "This Week
in Android Development."
Be sure to subscribe
to our channel
so you don't miss anything.
I'm Daniel Pham, and
remember to take your time,
hurry up, the choice is
yours, don't be late.